avait alors refusé sa demande d'asile
mais la semaine des as à dire la justice
administrative avait autorisé sa
présence sur le territoire national
effectivement manifestement a connu des
démêlés avec la justice puisqu'il a été
condamné suite à je crois une rixe à
arme blanche il a effectué sa peine de
prison
et puis suite au signalement du préfet
du département
il était convoqué il a été convoqué deux
fois par les services du ministère de
l'intérieur deux fois par l'ofpra
notamment une dernière fois à la fin
d'année dernière pour pouvoir lui dire
qu'il devait quitter le territoire
national et ne s'est pas rendu à ses
convocations et c'est sans doute en
attendant une prochaine convocation dans
la tente de la prochaine convocation lui
décidant parce qu'il avait justement
comme il ya un fait et qui avait été
condamné par la justice et que les
consignes que je donne mais ça n'a
d'ailleurs sont claires c'est que les
gens qui ont été condamnés pour des
crimes et délits doivent quitter le
territoire national
c'est parce qu'il devait quitter le
territoire national parce que l'ofpra
devait lui dire qu'il revenait sur la
décision de rester son territoire
national sans doute qu'il est venu ici
mais je crois que la procureure la
république aura l'occasion de détailler
des motivations s'il y en a